The next question from WhatsApp.
Assalamu alaykum sirkum.
I am Jamal from India. I am involved in
a business of wedding cards for the past
6 years. I have a doubt about selling
wedding cards with non-Muslim gods. Is
it okay sir? I have this doubt from the
beginning. Some say it's okay and some
say it's not okay to sell them. Please
sir, give me a good knowledge about
this. Thanks. The question poses that is
it permissible to sell wedding cards
with photographs of non-Muslim gods or
gods of non-Muslims? Actually the god
for Muslim and non-Muslim is the same.
It is Allah subhanaa tala. If you're
saying that the gods with the non-Muslim
worship that's a different thing. So
gods of the non-Muslims is the same
Allah subhanana wa tala gods of all the
human beings Allah subhanaa tala but I
know what a question was that can you
sell wedding cards on which there are
photos of gods which are worshiped by
non-Muslims the answer to this is no you
cannot sell cards or sell goods on which
there are photographs of the gods which
are worshiped by non-Muslim they are
doing shik and you're promoting it if
you're selling them cards with
photographs of the gods which they think
are gods and they worship and you sell
it to them. What are you doing? you're
helping them in shik it's totally haram
and there are various fatwas of top
scholars givea that you cannot wish the
non-muslims during the festivals you
cannot take part in the celebration you
cannot help them to give them goods in
which they are involved in doing wrong
activity during the festival so and
Allah subhanaa tala is very clear in
surah maida chapter number 5 verse
number two that Help one another in B
and tawa in righteousness and piety but
do not help one another in sin and
ranker. So what are you doing? You're
giving them wedding card with the
photographs of the false gods which they
worship. This is shik. So helping them
to do shik. So you cannot sell any goods
which promote things which are haram.
and selling wedding cards or birthday
cards or festival cards which have got
photographs of non-Muslim God is haram
or even selling goods which help them to
celebrate the non-Muslim festivals
encourage them or you're giving a
discount on Christmas saying that
Christmas sale or saying that there's a
Diwali sale and you're giving discount
and you know trying to allure them you
can give them discount there's no
problem but giving discount because it's
Diwali or giving discount on because
this Christmas trying to attract
customers. This is haram as per the
verse of the Quran of surah maida
chapter 5 number two that do not help
one another in sin and ranker. Hope that
answers the question.